- Well, Christmas is three weeks away.
So do you get into decorating?
'Cause you like decorating yourself,
so maybe you like decorating rooms.
- Christmas is my jam.
- Me Too.
(audience laughing)
Me too. I'm a crazy person.
Like Griswold.
- I am a crazy person.
- Yeah.
- What are you talking about?
- You have not seen what I do.
- Have you had a tree built?
- Do you mean-
- Do you have Christmas villages?
- Yes.
- (Taraji scoffs)
- Do I have a...
- Do I have a Christ-
- Christmas village!
- I wish...
- (Taraji exclaims)
- I have the whole Dickens, like, village
from way back in the day.
I have a...
Not a village, I have a city.
- I do too.
- Yeah.
- I have themes to my city.
Okay. Okay.
- Yes, okay.
- So I had this tree built.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Oh my God, I love this.
- [Taraji] See, that's my tree!
- I love that!
- I had it built.
(audience applauding)
- And so I had to put the
greenery on there myself.
- Yeah.
- And I had so many small...
My village is like, it's like you said.
It's a city.
- Yeah.
- So there're themes,
like you start in the
country at the bottom.
- Yeah.
- And you go
all the way up to the North Pole.
- [Kelly] You get the little pubs
and then you get, like, the bakeries.
- I have the animals,
I have the little figurines-
- Yes.
- The people. So its this-
- They're ice skating.
- Oh, the ice skating!
- Yeah, lamp post.
- And the carousels!
- Yes!
- (Taraji laughing)
- [Kelly] We are so similar!
- I have a climbing Santa.
- I don't have that.
- So Santa's climbing up-
- I have a flying one.
- Oh my God!
- Yeah.
- Where'd you get the flying one?
- I don't know.
Oh, I can't say the company.
I'll get in trouble.
- Okay, I know but-
(Kelly laughs)
- Offline, we'll talk.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Some things I need in my
village. (Taraji laughs)
- But it makes me happy.
- It makes me so happy.
- Yeah, all the lights.
- It's just when I walk past my tree,
I'm just like... (Taraji sighs)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
- [Taraji] I need that.
- Everything could be going
wrong and you're like,
but this makes me happy. Yeah.
- This makes me happy.
And I know my son is so
happy to be out of the house
(Kelly laughing)
- Because I would drive him crazy.
"Marcel, help me with this."
He would lose it.
I know he's happy.
- The only way I can get-
- He likes to come and see it, though.
- The only way I can get my
kids to help is if we build...
'Cause we also do Lego little villages.
So that we do, like, the
Christmas Lego things.
My son love that.
- Okay.
You might have me beat.
- [Kelly] No, I'm just saying.
- I'm a huge Lego dork, by the way.
- We should definitely exchange
information. (Kelly laughs)
- Because we need to go to Legoland
with no kids!
- I love Legoland!
- Oh, my God.
I love Lego... I just took my kids there.
- So we need to go with no kids!
- It's so crazy.
I told my kids to go nuts
in that Lego thing.
- I found my soul mate.
- I know, I'm just saying.
- I'm almost done building
Harry Potter's castle.
Like, Hogwarts.
- Oh, my God.
- So, yeah.
I am literally, like, really into it.
It's therapeutic.
- It is.
- You just sit there and it's so easy
and its my-
- You're a creator.
That's fine.
- Yes, yes.
- You're a creative person.
- I loved you before,
but I really love you now.
- I love you even... ooh!
- Yup, yup, yup.
We're gonna create a show, a movie.